dans les plus hautes sphères qu'on a vu
que les horloges en mouvement tourne
moins vite donc si vous abandonnez votre
jumeau sur terre pour faire le tour de
l'univers alors votre jumeau va vous
voir aller très vite et donc voir votre
horloge tourner moins vite et du coup
pendant que 50 ans passe pour votre
jumeau sur terre il est possible que
seulement un an de ce soit passé pour
vous dans votre vaisseau du coup que
vous reviendrez sur terre vous serez
plus jeune que votre jumeau tout va bien
vous êtes sûr
voyons maintenant ce qui se passe sinon
résonne dans votre référentiel dans
votre référentiel c'est votre jumeau qui
est en mouvement et c'est donc son
horloge qui tourne moins vite
du coup par le même raisonnement que
précédemment devrait conclure cette fois
que vous serez plus vieux que votre
jumeau qu'est ce qui se passe parce
qu'on a une contradiction fondamentale
au coeur de la relativité
la réponse de base pour résoudre ce
paradoxe consiste à faire à la remarque
que pour revenir sur terre
vous avez dû faire demi-tour un certain
point du coup vous n'êtes pas rester
dans un référentiel inertielle et la
relativité restreinte ne s'applique donc
pas à votre référentiel le deuxième
raisonnement que l'on a fait est donc
faux sauf quand relativité générale est
tout à fait possible comme trouver sow
et fait le tour de la galaxie et
reviennent sur terre et ce sans avoir
jamais accéléré
en voici un exemple tout bête décollé à
très grande vitesse et couper les
moteurs
vous suivrez une orbite autour de la
galaxie autre que celle que celui-là
terre et de façon cruciale le long de
cette trajectoire
vous ne subirez aucune force même pas la
force de gravité car la gravité n'est
pas une force du camp quand vous
reviendrai sur terre soirée vont plus
jeune au plus vieux que votre jeu la
réponse réside dans la métrique de
l'espace temps comme je le dis dans une
vidéo précédente le temps passe et on
est donc constamment en mouvement à
travers l'espace temps on suit nos
trajectoires à travers l'espace temps le
rythme qu'elle passe le temps dépend
alors justement de cette trajectoire
il se trouve que les trajectoires en
ligne droite sont des maximes isr locaux
du temps qui se passe entre deux points
d'eux n'est ce pas
temps alors le sens de ce que vient de
dire est en fait on peut donc à ce que
ça veut dire c'est que si l'on prend une
ligne droite à travers l'espace temps et
si on perturbe légèrement cette ligne
droite alors le temps va passer moins
vite le long de la trajectoire modifié
autrement dit si votre vos mots suit la
ligne droite et si vous suivez la ligne
dû modifier
alors au bout du chemin vous serez plus
jeune que votre jumeau prenant certain
sens on ne suivant pas la trajectoire en
ligne droite
vous avez fait de plus grands pas à
travers l'espace temps à chaque unité de
temps et du coup vous arriverez au bout
de trajectoire en moins de temps sauf
que contrairement à ce qui se passe dans
une course vous n'aurez pas à attendre
votre jumeau oui car je vous le rappelle
ce qui est dessiné et l'espace donc pas
l'espace ok mais qu'en est il maintenant
de deux lignes droites qui secoue pas de
reprise dans un espace-temps courbes
bien ça dépend de la courbure en
différents points de l'espace temps et
c'est là qu'il faut faire de longs
calculs très compliqué
pour faire simple en gros on peut dire
que les trajectoires qui traverse les
régions très courbé de l'espace-temps
fonde plus long pas à travers l'espace
temps à chaque pas de temps en
particulier si votre trajectoire se
rapproche très près d'un trou noir
alors c'est bien vous qui serez plus
jeune que votre jour et du coup comme
dans le film interstellar vous pouvez
finir plus vieux que des personnes qui a
été bien plus vieille que vous dans le
passé et si vous pensez que ça c'est
bizarre vous n'avez encore rien vu
à
en 1949 le mathématicien kurt gödel que
le considère souvent comme le plus grand
logicien de tous les temps sur prix
einstein pour son anniversaire avec un
cadeau assez peu ordinaire il offrit à
einstein une nouvelle solution
cosmologique incroyablement mystérieuse
aux équations de la relativité générale
l'univers de gödel était si courbet que
des trajectoires en ligne droite de
l'univers pouvait être ramené à boucler
sur elle-même autrement dit les
équations d'einstein autorisé le wild
brent voyage dans le passé si l'univers
est telle qu'un donne l'avait décrit
alors il existe des trajectoires à
travers l'espace temps en ligne droite
qui bouclent sur elle même c'est à dire
qu'ils reviennent dans leur passé super
bizarre si blizzard cannes stein
rejointe à la validité physique des
solutions de gödel bien qu'il
reconnaissait la validité mathématiques
se voile pas quelque chose qu'un jeune a
fini par regretter mais là pour le coup
j'ai vraiment du mal à aller à
l'encontre du rouget d'einstein et vous
pouvez imaginer pourquoi l'univers de
gödel n'interdit pas le paradoxe du
grand père
si vous pouviez revenir dans le passé
vous risqueriez de tués par accident
votre grand père
mais si votre grand père meurt avant
d'avoir donné naissance à votre père
lors votre père ne pourra pas vous
donner naissance et vous ne seriez pas
mais pire vous ne saurez pas retourner
dans le passé et vous n'auriez pas tuer
votre grand père qui aurait donc donné
naissance à votre père lequel bison est
double essence et dont vous seriez des
mêmes sans volonté vous a été le grand
perdant connaissance première mais
qu'elle voudra connais les sentiments
ça n'a aucun sens vous ne pouvez pas à
la fois être né et ne pas être né c'est
pourquoi la plupart des physiciens
rejette aujourd'hui la possibilité du
voyage dans le passé même si un logiciel
pur comme gödel ne pourrait pas se
permettre de rejeter une telle
possibilité à gaza je peux vous dire que
la relativité générale c'est pas le seul
domaine qui l'a complètement bouleversée
quelques décennies plus tôt que dell
avait déjà prouvé que la consistance des
mathématiques ne pouvait pas être prouvé
la dernière fois on a parlé de la
théorie du big bang et graphiques pvp
pose la question de la distance qui nous
sépare de cette origine de l'univers
alors pour dire ce que dit si souvent
etienne qu'un la preuve c'est à dire
c'est que le big bang n'est pas
forcément l'origine de l'univers selon
de la théorie du big bang de ce que l'on
peut dire c'est qu'il ya un passé très
lointain dans lequel tout était très
concentré et la théorie du big bang lui
dit que cette présentation de matières
s'est étendue dans à travers l'espace la
deuxième phase à dire c'est ce que dit
très bien
linux à savoir que le big bang en fête a
eu lieu partout c'est une expansion de
tout l'espace temps du coup tout point
de l'espace temps était un point du big
bang dans le passé duquel tout l'espace
temps observable si vous voulez en
savoir plus je vous conseille les vidéos
notamment d'y penser
donc il n'y a pas vraiment de distance
pas sial que nous séparent du big bang
puisque le point on était à l'origine un
point du big bang
cependant il y à une distance temporelle
qui nous séparent du big bang et là je
peux vous dire que le big bang se trouve
à 13,7 milliards d'années dans le passé
toutefois on peut poser une question un
petit peu différente à savoir où se
trouvent les particules qui ont émis la
lumière du fond diffus cosmologique que
l'on observe aujourd'hui sur terre et là
il faut faire un tout petit peu
attention puisque entre le moment où ces
particules ont émis cette lumière
et le moment où nous on la reçoit ces
particules se sont éloignés de nous
quand on fait les calculs on se rend
compte que la distance à laquelle se
trouvent ces particules aujourd'hui est
de 47 milliards d'années lumière
et comme ces particules sont les
particules les plus éloignés dont on
peut voir la lumière aujourd'hui
ceci amène certains à dire que la taille
de l'univers observable et 2,93
milliards d'années-lumière tome v nous
demande s'il est possible qu'il y ait eu
une soupe primordiale sans qu'il y ait
eu de big bang si on en croit la théorie
de la relativité générale en tout cas si
on suppose que l'espace est homogène on
doit appliquer à ce moment là les
équations de friedman et du coup si on
sait que dans le passé l'univers était
plus petit qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui il
ya plus 36 solutions il me semble qu'il
faut alors conclure qu' il ya eu un big
bang
ça correspond un petit peu à ce que
disait la place m'a proposé qu'aux de
newton où il disait que si un être
suprême était capable de connaître
toutes les positions des particules ans
pour donner et toutes les formes
d'interactions entre elles alors il
devrait pouvoir calculer le futur mais
aussi le passé puis connaîtrait en fait
tout de l'espace-temps juste en mesurant
ce qui se passe à l'instant présent pris
à des théories qui vont au delà de leurs
habiletés général donc si on sort de
quatre de la relativité générale j'ai
envie de dire que à ce moment là tout
est possible en particulier en théorie
des cordes banon je prends pas très
intérêts des cordes
mais apparemment le big bang serait un
robot ou quelque chose comme ça du coup
et pas vraiment eu de singularité en
tout cas la théorie des cordes permet
d'exclure toute singularité dans
l'espace temps enfin william veine elle
me reproche de ne pas avoir parlé de la
fantaisie de gamme of fame of rock c'est
un personnage haut en couleurs et en
particulier un moment dans la vidéo
précédente je vous ai parlé de alpher
better in game of une histoire assez
amusante derrière elle fera était alors
l'étudiant de gamme offre également
qu'un et c'est aussi très bien béto et
ils trouvaient ça juste marrant que
d'inclure bt dans la discussion parce
que ça faisait alpher beto gamme of donc
quasiment alfa beta gamma est d'ailleurs
le papier qu'ils ont écrit maintenant
connu sous le nom de papier afin bêta
gamma juste parce qu'il trouvait ça
marrant gamme of a décidé de rajouter le
nom de b tôt pour dire que better
n'avait pas vraiment participer
entièrement à tout ça il a même rajouté
à côté de better in abstentia et il a
envoyé chez papiers sauf que ce papier
est tombée dans les mains de ben et au
moment du peer review vêtu a tout de
suite compris la blague de gamme offre
du coup il a barré in abstentia
sous-entendant qu'il voulait faire
partie de cette blague historique que
voulait faire game of et j'espère que
vous avez aimé cet épisode de la
prochaine fois on va parler des trous
noirs de leur utilité rester uniquement
dans cadre d'or a été générale mais vous
allez voir que c'est déjà complètement
fou et ouvre à une approche aussi
malheureusement bientôt de la fin de la
série sur la relativité générale et du
pouvoir commencer une nouvelle série de
vidéos et je vous propose de voter pour
le thème de cette prochaine série de
vidéos je vous mets un client ici et
puis dans les descriptions vers un ou
deux formes où vous pourrez noter trois
propositions de thème pour la prochaine
série de tuyaux
donc je vous propose au choix les
fondations des mathématiques la théorie
des jeux ou
si vous avez aimé cet épisode n'hésitez
pas le lac est le commentaire est le
partage et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour
ne pas manquer les futurs épisodes
donnez moi des dons surtout pis si vous
le souhaitez et j'espère que je verrai
la prochaine fois demi-tour a pour effet
de faire pivoter l'acte de simultanéité
du voyageur ce dernier a donc
l'impression que la terre vieil-hesdin
seulement terminé